[Music]
okay
my secret is my secret is
my biggest secret is
[Music]
my secret is every female i told i loved
i cheated on
when i was in high school i photoshopped
my arch nemesis
to be fat in photos and posted them to
facebook
and i am so sorry about that
my secret is and i'm not sure if it's
even a secret
but i've failed in almost every aspect
of
my life like i've disappointed my
parents i've disappointed my girlfriend
i've failed as a husband and a father
that's my secret
[Music]
my biggest secret is that i can't stop
being a clown
i'm a professional clown i've dedicated
my life to
humanitarian work through laughter and
as much as i try to live a normal life i
can't i can't stop
making people laugh
that's uh i guess my gift and my curse
i wish i could have been a doctor but i
guess i'm a
i'm a laughter doctor
that's my biggest secret
[Music]
my secret is i collect my dog's
whiskers and it actually started
when my past family dogs their whiskers
started falling out
and i would collect them in this box for
some reason
and i have this total fascination with
whiskers
and only my boyfriend and my family
know about this so much so that my
sister
who has rabbits will collect
her rabbit's whiskers for me
in a special jar and
it's super weird but i don't know
whiskers
are like a whole different kind of hair
and it's fascinating
and i have an entire box dedicated to my
dog's whiskers
that's my secret
i'm no longer vegetarian i
basically stopped being vegetarian
at the beginning of quarantine because
well i basically thought [ __ ] the world
is ending
i might as well eat some chicken
[Music]
one time on 4th of july i was super
drunk and i had my friend's
jewel i took it to the bathroom and i
accidentally dropped it in the toilet
with my pee in it and we both used it
for like a week after that
[Music]
okay so i'm from i'm from texas but i
come here
at least once a year to walk through
this botanical garden
but last night when i walked through i
was extremely intoxicated
and i took a dump into the pond right
next to me
that's my extreme crazy secret
[Music]
when i was younger i used to try and
find stuff in my brother's room
and one day i found a usb so i plugged
it into the uh
the home computer and it was sex tape
i once went down to laboufadora mexico
met a hippie there
we entered the igloo and i did ayahuasca
and as the feelings started to come on
i started to not be able to feel my
heart anymore feel my breath
and i got a little nervous and i told
the guy i said i think i'm dying
and he said you are go into it and
that's where my mind started to think
that this guy
poisoned me because i didn't really know
him that well
and so i exited this teepee
or it was more like an igloo and he
called it the womb because
apparently when you get out of this
thing you're supposed to be reborn
and i get out of this thing and i was
like
screw it if this guy's gonna try to kill
me i'm gonna kill him first and so
i tried to attack him and he ran away
from me
it was really wet and muddy outside and
i ended up falling down like this
mountain
and lube fedora's got some pretty good
cliffs i ended up waking up in an
alley in the middle of this city in
mexico
all by myself it was wicked experience
very heavy
[Music]
i am 30 years old i still love my
[Music]
parents
i don't believe my parents truly love me
i believe they love
what they think about me and what i can
do for them
think some part of my mother hates me
[Music]
okay so my secret is is when i was about
eight years old
i had to pee really bad in class and my
teacher didn't let me go and so i
decided i was just gonna walk to the
corner of the room
like during like silent reading time and
just pee in the corner of the room
um and the next morning she confronted
us about it and she said if anyone knows
anything
just be honest and tell me and i totally
blamed it on this kid named manny
manny i'm so sorry i know you took the
fall for that and i just want to let you
know that i feel guilt about it
every day and i hope you're doing okay
[Music]
when i was in high school my senior year
my friend and i were the treasurers
and with the money that we would make
from selling in the concessions we would
take
like 25 and from there
practically our whole senior adventure
was paid off with the money that we were
making from school
and that's pretty much it
[Music]
i am secretly really mad at my husband
right now and i am
not having a good time because he
planned this whole excursion
really badly and everything was closed
and i think that's poor planning on his
part and it really
grinds my gears
is that your husband right there yeah
something that no one knows about me
is that i have spent several years
of my life under
water
[Music]
i hate my sister's boyfriend
he dulls her shine and
it's just a no for me dog
my family has made me hate them for
years they do things
on purpose to sabotage my dreams and
goals
but i'm so scared of being alone i
fantasize about leaving all the time and
just disconnecting from them but
i don't have to get to actually move
from san diego
[Music]
it's becoming less of a secret now but
still a secret to my entire family but i
am
trans femme and as i'm saying this
into a microphone in the middle of this
park i'm spotting
a lot of people staring right at me and
for the first time i'm
not bothered by it
hello everyone drya here um it's been a
while
and that's obviously because i'm trying
to play it safe with coronavirus
i wish i could make a video every week
but that wouldn't be very smart of me to
do
so for now my schedule is all over the
place but
i hope you'll continue to stay tuned
um i'm hoping to post twice a month
going forward but i'm not sure about
that because i want to feel it out
and see if it feels safe if it doesn't
then i'm going to stop that but
that's what i'm hoping for also i had a
favor to ask
of you guys i thought it'd be cool if
you guys suggested video ideas
that have nothing to do with meeting
strangers something you've never seen on
my channel
that you think i might be able to make
comment it down below and if i end up
making a video that you suggested
i'll give you a shout out i want to
thank you guys again
for everything i love you i miss
doing this as much as i used to but i'm
still here
so stay tuned and i'll see you when
i see you
you